i was legally blind when i woke up and
my little sister was at my bedside and i
was so blind that i couldn't see who she
was
demi lovato details her 2018 overdose
and the lasting impact it's had on her
health
i'm really lucky to be alive
um my doctors
said that like i had
five to ten more minutes um
and had my assistant not come in
i wouldn't be here today episode one and
two of the i love me singer's four-part
docu-series dancing with the devil
dropped tuesday on youtube and the 28
year old singer is getting candid about
the night she overdosed on heroin
her objective was to clear the air to
tell her story to speak her truth
demi explains that she was celebrating
her friend and creative director danny
vitale's birthday at a bar
in la at around 12 30 a.m demi invited
everyone back to her house where danny
says they drank sparkling water
and danced on the roof until they all
got tired and went home
i said i was going to bed but the
reality was
i had called my dealer over the next
morning
it was the singer's then assistant
jordan jackson who found her unconscious
in her bedroom
i thought that she was just drunk
or hungover so i kind of started to like
nudge her a little bit like hey like
let's get up now like it's time to go
she wasn't really moving
she was like drooling jordan said she
called demi's security
before then calling 9-1-1 the ambulance
came
they came upstairs to her room
they got their narcan out
trying to really just bring her back to
life
um there was one point where she turned
blue
i was just like she's dead
for sure yeah it was the craziest thing
i've ever seen
and while demi survived her od it didn't
come without complications
i actually don't think people realize
how bad it actually was
i had three strokes
i had a heart attack
i suffered brain damage from the strokes
i can't drive anymore
and i have blind spots in my vision
she gets into you know how bad that
night of the overdose really was
how scary it was i think people will
learn for the first time how truly life
or death that situation was
how tough was that for her to relive for
her family to relive
what were those interviews like tough i
mean all of the interviews were really
heavy
um this film you know dancing with the
devil ultimately is about a moment in
time
obviously that horrible incident where
the overdose occurred
and ultimately how we got there you know
it's ultimately this like nucleus and
you peel back the
layers of the onion in it and it all
leads you uh in a non-linear way to this
moment and i think a lot of the people
that i sat down with
hadn't properly spoken about it in the
open
to this level at any point e.t chatted
with michael d
ratner the doc's director and he
revealed why it was so important to demi
to lay it all out on the table
she um leaned into it and anything that
made her uncomfortable she understood
the power
of that and you know we say it right
there in the film you're not defined by
your lowest moments
and sharing those lowest moments um
should ultimately allow and invite
people to
talk about theirs and start a dialogue
and you know most importantly demi's not
telling anybody how to live their life
everybody's got their own unique
situations she's simply telling you what
she's been through her unique journey
and you know i think that will provide
an opportunity for others to do the same
it's not very common that you'd see
someone with a drug-related overdose
with this degree of multi-organ failure
that would come out of it
relatively unscathed and do as well as
she has
it's like a nice reminder that
that it wasn't my time you know that
there was more life to
be lived